للتواصل والحوار اهلا بك استاذ عماد نتوقف
معك بدايه عند وضع بخمه لن نتحدث عن
الامور العسكريه لكن هناك حديث من سلطنه
برج الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي عن ان
هذه المدينه قد تسقط خلال ايام يضاف الى
ذلك تصريحات لمجموعات فاجنر عن محاصرتها
وتطويقها شبه الكامل ما المعلومات
المتداوله في كياف خصوصا ان هناك ربما نفي
اوكراني لقرب او سقوط وشكل هذه المدينه
تحياتي لكم الاستاذ المشاهدين بالتاكيد
مدينه باخمت اصبحت ملحمه بطوليه للشعب
الاوكراني وللصمود الذي استطاعت خلال اكثر
من سبعه شهور ان تبقى عليه الان
الاجتماعات الرسميه اليوم تحديدا للقياده
العسكريه اضافه الى التشاور الذي كان
اليوم لرئيس القوات المشتركه الاوكراني مع
الامريكي مع وايضا البريطاني والبولندي
اكدت ان اوكرانيا ماضيه في الدفاع عن هذه
المدينه هذه المدينه بالتاكيد لم تسقط
المنطقه الغربيه مفتوحه بشكل كامل لادخال
الذخائر والمواد الغذائيه والمساعدات
للقوات المتواجده الان اوكرانيا تحاول قدر
المستطاع الصمود في هذه المدينه ريثما
يصلها مدد نوعي ربما تقلب المعادله فيه
لتصبح يعني استنزاف للقوات الروسيه التي
فعلا
استنزفت واصبحت قوات فاجنر رسميا تعلن
بشكل علني انها لم تحصل على الذخيره
الكامله لحسم هذه المعركه في هذه النقطه
استاذنا عماد هل ربما هناك وزراء دفاع
الاتحاد الاوروبيه المجتمعون الذين
سيجتمعون في ستوكهولم اليوم لبحث مساله
امداد كييف بمزيد من القذائف
ودعم العسكري بالت الي بالنظر الى وضع هذه
المدينه هل يعد ذلك فشلا غربيا في مساعده
كياب الحفاظ على هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه
ام ربما يعود ذلك الى استراتيجيه روسيه قد
تكون ربما ناجحه في المرحله في الحاليه في
الشرق الاوكراني خصوصا لجهه كل ما يقال عن
باعتقادي من السابق لا وان نقول ان
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه نجحت فاذا كانت
مدينه باقمه تاخذ كل هذه الشهور ما بالنا
لو كان الاشتياح على بقيه المدن
الاوكرانيه او حتى مهاجمه دول اوروبيه
كانت بعض الاحيان تصدر التصريحات للقياده
الروسيه باستهدافها باعتقادي نعم ربما كان
تاخير للناتو قبل الحرب وتحديدا 2021
بامكانيه دعمه اللازم لاوكرانيا لم يعتقد
الاتحاد الاوروبي والناتو انه اوكرانيا
يمكن ان تحدث كل هذه المفارقه الشاسعه
والتضحيه البطوليه التي حمت او بنظر
كثيرين تحمي الاوروبا من
التهديدات الروسيه اذا الواقع الحالي يشير
ان اوروبا لم تنقسم وهي ماضيه في دعم
اوكرانيا طيب اعود ايضا لمساله بخمو دائما
وهي استراتيجيه طبعا استاذ عماد
الاوكرانيين رغم نفهم يتحدثون عن الضغوط
التي يواجهها التواجه والقوات
الاوكرانيه على الارض ما توقعاتك بالنسبه
لهذه المدينه
حقيقه من الصعب التكهن بشيء لماذا لان
روسيا في هذه الحرب هي اصبحت لها حرب
اساسيه لان عدم تحقيقها لحسم هذه المعركه
والسيطره عليها يعني فشل ذريع لقوات فاجنر
اولا التي لن تراهن عليها القياده
السياسيه الروسيه سلاحقا ثم لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تحديدا فلاكن هل هذا الامر يمكن
كل شيء وارد وان كان الامر ليس بتلك
السهوله لماذا لانني ذكرت ان روسيا تحشد
معدات كبيره واستنزفت يعني خمس اضعاف
خسائر اوكرانيا خسرتها القوات الروسيه
بالتاكيد ولكن الامر يستمر في تصعيد
المتزايد عماد ابو الرب رئيس المركز
الاوكراني للتواصل والحوار حددنا من كيف